what's up
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
it's actually a wrong approach it's
misdirected
it goes against
you know the norms as advised by the who
and we we just we just feel that
some of the leadership of countries are
finding scapegoats
to deal with what is a worldwide problem
[Music]
you're not going to see
a new vaccine in the next few weeks or
even you know the next month or so but
it's going to take longer than that but
it will not take the amount of time that
it would normally take to manufacture
and deliver a vaccine it can be done at
speed now because of the understanding
and knowledge that we have
we know that the mutations that we're
seeing this are troublesome in that we
believe that they may evade some of the
vaccines out there but it's highly
unlikely that vaccines will be rendered
completely useless what needs to happen
now is that the lead needs to stop being
travel bans that is a scapegoat the lead
needs to be what we're doing to ramp up
efforts to increase global vaccine
equity which includes supply which
includes manufacturing which includes um
releasing patents but also includes
helping with funding so that governments
can deal with valid mistrust in these
communities mistrust by the way that's
only made worse by decisions such as the
ones that have been made this week